so we recently did an episode of visual
effects artist react where we talked
about Halo and there were a ton of
comments saying we got to make something
in the Halo Universe
well it's funny you should mention that
it's a massive Halo fan I played all the
games I've read a bunch of the books and
in high school I even tried to build a
warthog
it's one of my favorite games of all
time is Halo 3 ODST I've always wanted
to tell a more grounded Halo story just
like that game now that I'm here at
Corridor I think I might finally be able
to make that dream come true
Corridor Digital was started with video
game Phantoms way back with Frozen
Crossing
but that was directed by Sam and Nico
now if I'm going to convince those two
to allow us to use all of the awesome
resources we have in the studio I'm
going to need to make something that's
really going to blow their minds
lucky for me I've got my buddy Jonah
with me hey
Jonah and I are going to try and create
enough of this project in our free time
so that we can piece together a trailer
to show to Sam and Nico the goal with
this trailer is to hopefully blow their
minds and get their support to produce a
whole Halo short film
so the Halo TV show on Paramount plus
might have left a bad taste in your
mouth AI off I'm enter I'm entering
myself to the rest of the team go
disappear
they did a lot of things right with that
show the VFX is pretty sweet but they
kind of just missed the mark on what a
Halo story should be wow
[Music]
Don there's been awesome Halo live
action content that's been created
already we had forward onto Dawn you had
Neil blomkamp's landfall trailers and
one of my favorites is the we are ODS
and trailer
it encapsulates everything that a Halo
live action piece can be it really
brings you down to a human level you
know the attention isn't on these crazy
Spartan super soldiers it's just on the
average everyday men and women that are
supposed to be serving in the UNSC it
feels a lot more gritty and real it's
more of like Band of Brothers rather
than Power Rangers which was kind of the
feeling a lot of people got from the
Paramount show
for our film I want to tell a more
grounded story that's focused more on
The Human Side of Things rather than
trying to be an all-encompassing Space
Opera the reality is I don't have the
resources to just go out there and have
my 10 million dollar an episode budget
get all these amazing props and costumes
huge sets and all that but what we do
have is access to the in-game models
[Music]
with using the game assets what's great
is we're staying true to the original
the incredible artist at 343 Industries
and Bungie before them have already done
the work and created the assets that
quintessentially are Halo I started this
process by manually ripping files from
the games and in that process I
discovered there are actually some
awesome Discord communities these
Discord communities have great people
taking assets from the Halo games and
optimizing them for use in blender which
is my 3D program of choice and the one
I'll be using to create this short film
so because all of these assets and
environments are pre-set up it really
feels like just playing with action
figures or this really kind of advanced
form of Machinima you ever wonder if I
were here it's one of the light screen
Mysteries isn't it Machinima was a form
of filmmaking where you're basically
just taking in-game footage and creating
your animated story based on that red
versus blue and Brewster teeth in
general was such a huge part of Halo's
growth and community so what we're doing
is like that but just with so much more
control we can you know really block out
our scenes control the cameras a lot
more rather than trying to nail a take
in one go with just an Xbox controller
so we figured out the technical side of
how to actually make this thing now
comes the more important part is how do
we actually tell a good story John and I
have both been working on this short
film for quite a while just in our spare
time because there's a ton of other
stuff going on at Corridor that we have
to focus on during the day
foreign
[Music]
it's been a labor of love and we have a
script we're really happy with
but it's one thing to write a story it's
another to take that story and turn it
into a full short film especially when I
am trying to create these sequences of
blender all on my own just like the
rookie and Halo 3 ODST I'm a bit of a
one-man Army here I'm gonna have to be
rendering each one of these shots all by
myself I don't have an entire Animation
Studio here working with me so I need to
be incredibly meticulous on how I'm
doing these shots we need to go through
really concisely break down our script
and make a really clear shot list and
storyboard of how we're going to do this
thing more specifically we need to make
sure we have everything we need for this
trailer that's going to include a radio
edit from our actors and very specific
shots that we're going to be using to
cut this trailer piece together
so now that we've got our method down on
how to create this thing we have our
story the next big hurdle to overcome is
how do we actually bring life to these
characters and have their performance
come through so originally when we were
first concepting out this whole short
film I was using a combination of hand
animation and pre-made miximo animations
and it was super tedious and not really
working all that well the reality is I
don't have time to animate all these
shots and I'm a terrible animator I'm
just not good at it at all but what we
do have is access to some really awesome
motion capture technology
I'm using the Rococo smartsuit Pro 2.
it's super awesome and the people at
Rococo have been super helpful best part
is there's a plug-in and blender that
allows me to just really quickly take my
motion capture data and transfer it
right onto the character rig so that I
can have fully animated motion capture
performance on all of our characters
since starting to use the Rococo suit
it's made my process about 10 000 times
faster I can actually just set up a
whole sequence of shots act it all out
and then just render the whole sequence
with different cameras it's so much
faster and has made my life so much
easier one of the coolest parts for me
in this process has been the moment
where I was actually able to play back
all of my motion capture data in real
time in blender and see the characters
moving around acting out the performance
that I had done in the motion capture
suit it was really the moment where I
was like okay we can actually do this
we've got story lockdown we've got our
process lockdown animation is covered I
have what I need to create the specific
shots necessary for a trailer which
Jonah has pieced together with the
placeholder shots one final effort is
All That Remains actually rendering all
of these shots but if I was just
rendering these things on any old PC at
home I'd probably start a fire
so the deadline is coming up really
quick here on this trailer and we need
to get this thing in front of samaniko
there's still a ton of VFX shots to get
through here
luckily I have a solution
fugit systems has been a huge supporter
of corridor digital for many years
they've hooked us up with a ton of
awesome workstations so we've linked
together every single Puget system
workstation we have in the studio to
create a render Farm
I'm runnery on this one right now
and this one too
I'm even rendering on this one
and this one
oh why
ah thanks Matt we wouldn't be able to do
what we do here at Corridor Digital
we're at not for the awesome people over
at Puget systems they tailor specific
computers for our needs whether it's
blasting out a ton of high quality
renders or deep diving into Ai and
machine learning they're able to create
custom built computers that fit your
needs whether you're working at a
professional level or just taking your
first steps into learning the effects
they can create a computer that will be
everything you need click the link in
the description below or go to
pugetsystems.com to find out more and in
just a few days Puget systems is even
starting to ship to Canada which is very
important for a Canuck like me whether
you're in Vancouver or all the way on
the east coast in Newfoundland and
Labrador they'll send you a Puget system
right to your door
cheers to that it's maple syrup by the
way
oh it's so sweet
so there's still a lot of work to get
through and I foresee a couple of late
nights in Gemini's future the most
important part of this trailer is that
we convey to Sam and Nico that this is a
project worth pursuing so we need the
trailer to get that across
okay
[Music]
banana
dude
that was great it's beautiful it's very
beautiful that's a very beautiful song
Thank you but it's going to take a
little bit more than a beautiful song
to impress us I've heard Jonah and
Penner have this Halo video that they
want to make and it's super ambitious I
really want to see them succeed but I
have no idea how they're going to pull
it off
and so I need a little bit of convincing
that they can pull it off I know you can
make some cool shots but can you put
them together in the right order
[Laughter]
we've worked really really hard on this
it's very near and dear to both our
hearts and we're so happy that we can
share this with you all without further
Ado I think we just play this thing
why are you here
the people stationed here are my
responsibility
where is everyone
the base is compromised we need to leave
we don't have the
way just to walk away
I know
you guys see that
we have a chance of Our Own
and that's what we do
it
my motion tracker reads friendly
movement
if the art
nobody move
[Applause]
oh
look at that
pretty cool that's pretty sick I've
never seen a plasma sword that big
before and that piqued my interest
I love the feel of like the environment
and like the sense of being in a place
capturing like the vibe so it's like oh
I'm back there and again you know it's
like and I'm seeing it in this like High
Fidelity imagined ways it's really cool
this feels like the Halo 3 commercials
[Laughter]
one shot in particular stands out it's
the close-up of the visor that was not
CG in that visor was it that's our very
own Jordan Coleman oh it's JC we
basically shot JC on the green screen
and then just applied that on like a
card that was tracked inside the helmet
sick the the Gatling gun shot seeing a
hand come down and spin it like that
that's a super nice touch the shots are
crispy obviously you want them extra
crisp and they're super crispy but at
the same time I I love all like the
weird like lens effects that are going
on it makes it feel a little bit more
raw when we were watching the shots from
the TV show that was the big problem
with that it was clean it was so clean
it was like on a set you know it felt
like a TV show suddenly and it didn't
feel like all right here's these
Commandos going to a hostile Planet it
obviously looks super sick but more
importantly like the fact that you guys
have more than two shots done
like having the challenge of doing the
trail actually helped us like speed up
our workflow because we were working
through some scenes and then you said
let's see a trailer and we kind of fast
tracked and were able to work through a
lot of different types of scenes and
that gave us the opportunity to like
hammer out the workflow for each one of
those scenes using blender motion
capture nuke all the resources we have
it feels doable now you guys could keep
poking away at this and that's cool but
it's gonna take a long time to come out
it'll be awesome if everybody here could
just like buckle down and work together
and get a video out which would be super
cool for us to do that really comes down
to everyone on the website helping
support this because it's up to you guys
to let us do these kind of projects
where we truly all take time and just
focus on it from your direct support so
I'm down
if everybody watching on the website is
down everybody in YouTube
it's cool hi
these kind of things are really dictated
by us having the ability to be free from
ads and sponsors and things like that
which we can only do with our you know
the direct support of the audience but I
think we should try and make it happen
so let's keep working on it let's make
it happen
I have you I love it
let's do it
oh
foreign